hello everyone and welcome to today's
broadcast improving sepsis management
with same-day results from the lab it is
presented by John McDonough the
president and CEO of t2 bio systems I am
Judy O'Rourke of laberd's and I'll be
your moderator for today's events we're
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by lab roots lab
reduce the leading scientific social
networking website and producer of
educational virtual events and webinars
before we begin I'd like to remind
everyone this event is interactive we
encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation just click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen and type your questions into
the drop-down box it appears on the
screen our speaker will respond to your
questions via email if you have trouble
seeing or hearing the presentation
please click on the africa question box
to let us know that you're having a
problem this presentation is educational
and thus offers continuing education
credits please click on the continuing
education credits tab located in the top
right corner of the presentation window
and follow the process to obtain your
credits please join me in welcoming John
McDonough I will now turn the
presentation over to him
much duty and thank you for listening in
today delighted to have the opportunity
to present T to direct diagnostics and
our products that are all geared towards
improving sepsis management within
within the lab a teaching Biosystems is
located in Massachusetts the technology
behind a company comes out of MIT at
Massachusetts General Hospital and what
we've developed at t2 is what we believe
is a breakthrough diagnostic platform
that combines advances in the field of
magnetic resonance with advances in the
field of nanotechnology and what this
technology is able to do for the first
time is to detect the presence of
infectious disease and other targets
directly in patient's clinical samples
as complex as whole blood at lower
concentration levels than any other
product that's that's in the market
we've initially focused this platform in
the whole field of rapidly identifying
sepsis causing pathogens arguably the
biggest unmet need and medical
diagnostics there are between one and a
half and two million patients a year in
the United States alone that number more
than triples on a worldwide basis who
will suffer these infections and over
all today there's a 20 to 25 percent
mortality rate the challenge with these
infections is that there are many
different sources of the infection from
different bacterial species to fungal
species and they present in patients
blood at very low concentration levels
typically between 1 and 10 colony
forming units per ml and there's been no
diagnostic detector that can detect at
those levels so patients are primarily
being treated through empiric therapy
while the diagnostic approach is one
where blood is Rhon and cultured over a
one to many day period that can take as
much as six days and knowing the exact
species of the infection is what is
critical in order to get patients or the
right targeted therapy data has
demonstrated that if you can get
patients on the right targeted therapy
within 12 hours you can cut mortality
rates in half and actually cut the cost
to treat patients by 20 to $30,000 per
inside
good patient we'll talk more about this
as I go through the presentation there
are over 200 peer-reviewed publications
related to the t2 technology and as a
company over the last several years
we've developed a global reach where our
products are in use at over 150
hospitals in the United States Europe
and the Middle East all supported by a
worldwide clinical and customer service
team there have been many independent
customer studies that have demonstrated
the proven impact on our products for
both patients and economics with typical
economic returns expected to be in the
range of three to five times the return
of the overall investment t2 also has
exciting partnerships with the CDC for
the superb detection of the superbug at
Canada Oris which is also in use at some
hospitals in the United States and we
have collaborations with Allergan said
Eric and Canon USA around developments
in the area of resistance panels in
early detection of Lyme disease the
technology behind t2 as I mentioned
combines advances of the field of
magnetic resonance with nanotechnology
and the breakthrough here is that when
when a probe binds to a target in a
clinical sample we're enabled at that we
enable that to change the overall
magnetic properties of all of the water
in the clinical sample the case of
sepsis the sample is a whole blood
sample and when those magnetic
properties change we detect it because
this is a completely non optical
approach to diagnostic detection there's
no sample preparation required
prior to loading on the instrument and
there's also no sample cleanup required
where target is required to be extracted
from the original sample or where the
background of the sample needs to be
removed instead all of that remains
intact which is what enables us to have
breakthrough limits of detection or even
on our FDA labels we show limits of
detection as low as one colony farley
per ml
in the early days of t2 we had some big
breakthroughs in terms of our ability to
bring this overall diagnostic method to
market all of those breakthroughs are
not manifested in 60 issued patents
around the world and another 40 that are
in various patent offices in the United
States and other countries as well in
those early days we were challenged with
knowing where to focus this technology
these breakthrough limits of detection
can apply to so many fields fields
related to hemostasis cancer diagnostics
and many others what we looked for is
our areas where we could provide a true
competitive advantage look for areas
that could represent a true breakthrough
in patient care where we could
potentially save and improve the lives
of patients while also at the same time
reducing the overall costs of the
healthcare system of treating whatever
that disease may be the initial cost
some of the initial concepts behind t2
were focused in the area of ministered
eyes Diagnostics where we used magnets
that were all the way down to the size
of a penny today as we developed our
overall footprint we've developed a t 2d
x instrument that is about 3 feet by 2
feet in size can run seven patient
samples and random access where the
ease-of-use concept is as simple as
taking a standard purple-top vacutainer
that contains three to four ml of blood
from the patients that tube is snapped
onto a cartridge that contains our
reagent and then put in side of one of
these seven drawers very simple to use
but very very high power limit of
detection as we detect all the way down
to single cells
the breakthrough in sepsis is that as
many of you probably know the only way
to detect species today in any
meaningful way starts with a blood
culture blood culture has been the gold
standard for about 90 years the reason
why blood culture has been that standard
is that again patients are presenting at
very low cell concentration levels of
the pathogen in their bloodstream in an
order for it to be detected every other
diagnostic platform requires more cells
to be present so the blood is incubated
typically for one to five days and then
once that blood culture goes positive
then it's moved to another platform
there are many other platforms that can
be used where it can take anywhere from
two to an additional 24 hours to
identify what grew in that blood culture
broth the challenge is that overall
process is thinking 1 to 6 days and this
is in a space where every hour of
delaying therapy is increasing patient
mortality rates by about 8% and if you
straight-line the cost of treating
patients cost for treating patients are
increasing by 200 to $500 per hour while
you delay getting patients on the right
targeted therapy additionally one of the
big challenges of blood culture is
sometimes those those cells just don't
grow in the five-day incubation period
and typically only 50 to 65 percent of
the time it will meaning that 35 to 50
percent of the time false negative
results are being being directed from
the blood culture sample that's why it's
not uncommon for for blood cultures to
be wrong further delaying the time to
result as typically those blood draws
are spread out over a longer period of
time at t2 we require 4 ml of blood
instead of 20 ml of blood that blood is
loaded onto an instrument and we provide
results in three to five hours those
results are species specific results
that enable targeted therapy
additionally if you look at our FDA
labels for both of our fda-cleared
products we detect over 90% of the
infections and in studies that have been
run by many customers we consistently
see that we're typically detecting
between 90 and 96% of
sections versus that gold standard of 50
to 65% and all of that with a 20 to 40
times improvement in the time to result
with time matters in terms of the health
of the patient we have three products in
the market today the teacher DX is our
instrument which I spoke about just a
couple of minutes ago additionally we
have our teach to Canada a diagnostic
panel that was FDA cleared has been in
the market map for about three years
the key to Canada panel provides species
specific results for the five major
targets of Canada infections our teacher
bacterial panel was FDA cleared in May
of 2018 the FTT to bacterial panel
targets the five most important
organisms that have been proven to be a
part of what is referred to as the
escaped pathogens this panel detects 90%
of the most problematic infections that
patients can have additionally these are
typically the infections that are not
covered by first line in Pyrrhic therapy
so the combination of first-line empiric
therapy with running the teaching
bacterial panel on patients can enable
90% or more patients to get on the right
targeted therapy and as fast as six
hours
you
the delay in blood culture results the
real gold standard in treating patients
today is in periodic therapy where
hospitals develop probability based
protocols based on infections they're
seeing in their institution and those
broad-spectrum antibiotics are typically
administered to any patient that's
suspected of having a sepsis infection
and then every 12 24 to 24 hours
additional antibiotics or antifungals
may be delivered to the patient if the
patient's not responding to that empiric
therapy that was initially deployed to
the patient
t-too what we're doing is providing
species specific results within three to
five hours this enables empiric therapy
practice to be significantly improved
current empiric therapy will typically
enable thirty to sixty percent of
patients to be immediately put on to
effective therapy the combination of t2
with current protocols can enable ninety
percent of patients to be on effective
therapy within six hours a major
breakthrough for the patient and a major
potential for cost savings for the
hospital
our objective at t2 is all about getting
patients on the right therapy as fast as
possible hospitals understand this which
is why empiric therapy protocols have
been established even though as much as
50 to 80 percent of the time that
interior therapy is not necessary
because patients may not have any
infection at all by enabling patients to
get on the right therapy as fast as
possible we enable the potential to
improve patient outcomes potentially
reducing mortality rates and morbidity
reducing the length of stay for patients
in the hospital in ICU and enabling more
rapid treatment for patients suspected
of sepsis this approach also enables
improves stewardship by reducing the use
of antibiotics and antifungal drugs
where rapid negative results can
represent opportunities to de-escalate
therapy that's being administered to a
patient or to rapidly adjust and provide
better management of drug costs and then
as a whole a big part of our value
proposition is to reduce the cost of
sepsis management reduced cost
reductions from early discharge
typically four to seven-day reduction of
length of stay in the hospital and/or
intensive care unit for the patient
reductions and costs of antimicrobial
drugs and also improved reimbursement
for discharge patients in the emergency
department
you
the T 2 DX instrument requires no sample
preparation in minimal hands-on time for
sample for the operator what's required
is a clean work environment with which
virtually all microbiology labs have the
technicians simply unpacks and assembles
a cartridge a reagent tray and a sample
Inlet module that enables the blood to
be snapped onto the cartridge and then
that overall system is then loaded onto
the TT 2 DX instrument the instrument
takes it from there providing results in
three to five hours both rapid positive
and negative test results
you
we have proven to provide 40 times
faster time to result some blood culture
based on clinical practices our typical
time to result on average would be about
four hours and can be as much as five
days for blood culture if it goes
through its full incubation period
clinically we've been enable at
Eightfold reduction in the time to
appropriate therapy for the patient
enabling patients to get on to the right
therapy within five hours with our
system as opposed to forty four hours
with blood culture and all of this is
meaning to desire time to result which
practitioners practitioners in an
independent survey communicated was
critical in terms of them changing
clinical decisions based on getting time
to results in about five hours
you
there have been many clinical studies
related to the t2 technology all of them
demonstrate clinical sensitivity of our
products in the 90 to 100 percent range
for 10 bacterial and fungal pathogens
these studies have been running in five
independent studies covering more than
300 confirmed infections the proven
clinical specificity of our products is
98.5% which has been demonstrated
through many independent studies
covering over 3,000 patients in more
than 15 institutions around the world
publications have estimated that the
negative predictive value of both t2
bacteria and t2 Canada is over 99% and
typically in the range of 33 to 92% in
terms of positive predictive value the
range really being dependent upon the
prevalence of the disease for specific
patient populations
I mentioned earlier our products are in
use in over a hundred and fifty
institutions around the world and there
are now many independent studies
publications and presentations that have
occurred at symposium and Industry
conferences demonstrating the overall
value of our products the Henry Ford
Health System for example ran a
statistically significant study looking
at the impact of our products both the
sick by analyzing patient cost but the
six months before the six months after
they implemented t2 they're now seeing a
reduction in the medium time of length
of stay in an intensive care unit of a
patient by seven days and the overall
length is safer patient has been reduced
by four days and negative test results
have led to a significant reduction in
the use of antimicrobial drugs providing
further savings for the institution and
health savings for the patient the Lee
Health System down in Florida has
published similar data showing a median
reduction in the length of stay in the
hospital for patients by seven days
they've demonstrated that they're
essentially paying for the cost of the
t2 tests purely through antifungal drug
savings alone not even including the
length of stay savings similar studies
and similar results have been realized
at Huntsville Hospital in Alabama and
Riverside Community Hospital out in
California
as I mentioned the teaching bacteria
study the teacher bacterial product was
FDA cleared in May going back to last
year the we're an atypical study in
eleven different sites across the
eastern United States in total we
collected fourteen hundred and twenty
seven patient samples where blood was
drawn concurrently where one was run on
a blood culture and one was run on the
t2 system the t2 bacteria panel targeted
the organisms E coli D faciam pneumonia
oregano sa' and also staph aureus the
end point was to compare the t2 result
with the blood culture result and then
there was a discordant analysis where
other cultures were looked at for the
patient both the 14 days around the 14
days of the paired t2 blood culture draw
in that clinical study where in total
there were 17 hundred and twenty seven
samples in the prospective arm of the
study average sensitivity was
demonstrated of 90 percent with a
ninety-eight percent average specificity
in the contrived or seated arm of the
study where cells were spiked into no
negative samples t2 demonstrated an
average sensitivity of 97% and an
average specificity of 99%
additionally in those cases where t2 was
positive in blood culture was negative
which is represented in the average
specificity through the discordant
analysis it was demonstrated that over
half of those t2 positives were in fact
real positive results and that the blood
culture had completely missed it in fact
if you assume that all of those
positives were true positives as
reflected in the analysis then blood
cultures overall sensitivity in this
study was under 40 percent where t2
Everage sensitivity was well over 90%
in the study of these 1427 patients
there were almost 36 patients that had
not received antibiotics 72 hours prior
to the t2 blood draw and 64% that had
received an antibiotic almost 39% had
actually received two or more
antibiotics 72 hours before the blood
draw 7151 percent of all of the subjects
or 866 patients out of 1427 we're
actually on an antibiotic therapy that
was effective against at least one of
the t2 bacterial panel members yet the
overall infection rate among patients
was closer to 10% despite the fact that
61% were on some kind of therapy
additionally if you look at the boat the
combination of the t2 positives in the
blood culture positives of which there
were a total of 35 only 31% of those
patients were actually on effective
therapy at the time of the draw even
those over 60 percent of the overall
patient population was on that therapy
demonstrating that empiric therapy has
significant limitations so 69 percent of
those patients were not are an effective
therapy and had that t2 result been able
to be used for the patient there would
have been an opportunity for 24 out of
35 patients to get on the right targeted
therapy likely one or more days faster
than they otherwise might have eighty
percent of the subjects were on
effective therapy within 24 hours after
the after that last blood draw
so in conclusion the teacher bacteria
results really offer an opportunity to
enable changes in therapy to occur more
than two days faster than the current
standard of care across all the subjects
in the trial 3.9% could have potentially
been placed on an effective therapy
faster after receiving a positive t2
bacterio result further an additional 5%
could have benefited from confirmation
that the therapy they were receiving was
effective potentially offering
opportunities to de-escalate from other
therapies so in total almost 9% of all
trial subjects could have benefited from
a t2 positive bacteria test result
some of the preliminary experience with
the teaching bacteria in the United
States has been quite exciting
in one case an elderly male patient on
hemodialysis with a recent
hospitalization for vancomycin recent
resistance bacterium developed a fever
of 102 degrees and became hypotensive
during that period of time they were
this patient was directly admitted
through the emergency department and
seen by the infectious disease doctors
prior to the administration of
antibiotics two sets of blood cultures
were drawn and titi bacteria was run as
a part of the overall TT bacteria
clinical study the teaching bacteria
came back positive the blood cultures
were negative and there was an
opportunity in this case to get this
patient on the right targeted therapy
much faster than what actually occurred
and another patient with a bacterial
infection they were honored effective
therapy a repeated blood cultures the
next day were negative but the TT
bacteria was positive what this
demonstrates is the potential for
managing patients to know when
infections have cleared you see blood
cultures have a significant limitation
once you put a patient on the right
targeted therapy because blood culture
requires cell growth and when you
administer antibiotics the antibiotics
prevent cell growth leading to a very
high rate of false negative test results
for blood culture TT bacteria is not
impeded and this was demonstrated in the
FDA clinical trial is not impeded by the
presence of antibiotic drugs therefore
making it a potentially powerful tool
for managing patients through the
clearance of the infection process in
the third case two blood culture sets
were drawn from a febrile patient with a
suspected bloodstream infection that had
been consented over the weekend for the
T to study TT bacteria was run the
following day and was positive for staph
aureus later blood cultures also became
back positive for staph aureus but much
later than when the teaching bacteria
result had been provided again
representing an opportunity to get
patients on
the right targeted therapy many hours
faster than otherwise occurred li health
down in Fort Myers in Cape Coral Florida
ran a exciting study that I'd like to
present to you regarding the T to
bacterial panel we help is the fourth
largest public health care system in the
United States a not-for-profit community
hospital with four adult
acute care facilities and over 1,400
beds the primary outcome in this study
was to determine if teaching bacteria
would provide faster identification of
infections enabling faster treatment in
this study the time to results of t2
bacteria averaged less than four hours
while the average blood culture result
came back in over 24 hours representing
a 20 hour time difference importantly t2
bacteria had a comparable time to result
for negative infections averaging three
point seven hours versus 122 hours for
blood culture results
second outcome of the study was to
determine if there were results
available that would create possible
opportunities for de-escalation and/or
intervention in total 23 patients were
run and a total of 36 opportunities were
identified for de-escalation of therapy
a de-escalating coverage for many
different infections the de-escalation
was valued on being able to discontinue
or deescalate based on rapid negative
test results the conclusion of the
League Health Study is that the teacher
bacterial panel allowed testing from
whole blood samples and provided final
results within four hours identifying
orgonite organisms twenty hours faster
than blood culture and 122 hours faster
for negative test results the teaching
bacteria panel also detected a greater
number of pathogens a greater number of
infections and there were numerous
opportunities for stewardship
intervention that were identified in the
secondary findings of the study
you
as you can see on this slide there are a
large number of independent
peer-reviewed publications using both
the teacher candidate eg bacterial
panels for further information please
feel free at any time to visit our
website or to reach out directly to t2
and would be happy to direct you or
provide you with with those various
publications all of the great work at t2
is all comes about because of a
tremendous team that is that has been
developed over the last eleven years
this is a team that truly cares about
patients that has demonstrated
perseverance in building this platform
and introducing this innovation and new
technology to the market and we're all
really proud of what it is worth
accomplished and proud of each other as
a team we believe that the ability to
detect pathogens directly from blood has
the opportunity to change medical
diagnostics in a really profound way t2
in what we have accomplished we are the
only fda cleared product that does not
require blood culture that can take a
blood sample and directly provide
results species specific results this is
a major breakthrough for patients and
one of the deadliest diseases affecting
hospitals in the United States sepsis is
responsible for almost 50% of deaths and
US hospitals on an annual basis it is
the most expensive Hospital treated
condition we will continue to work hard
to bring additional new products to
market and we hope they have the
opportunity to continue to work with the
healthcare system to make a difference
in the lives of patients and with that
I'll turn it back to the moderator thank
you John for that informative
presentation we will now start the Q&A
portion of the webinar and we'll address
some of the most commonly asked
questions by our viewers if you have any
questions you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on the ask a question
drop-down box located on the far left of
your presentation window type your
question into the box that appears on
your screen and click the send button or
speaker we'll follow up with your
questions via email let's get started
our first question is what patient
selection crike
area should hospitals use for these
pests that's a great question
with in virtually every hospital they
establish a sepsis protocol that sepsis
protocol is in play for patients
presenting in the emergency department
where typically about 50% of these
infections occur and also within the
hospital another 50% of these in
sections are often acquired while a
patient is in a hospital and the best
place to use the t2 product of the t2
bacterio product specifically is to make
it a part of a hospital sepsis protocol
what we're seeing is is that the typical
hospital is starting to put t2 bacteria
in the emergency department sepsis
protocol and then as they gain
experience expanded into the hospital
settings by being a part of the sepsis
protocol it means that when a patient
meets certain clinical criteria where
they're suspected of having a sepsis
pathogen infection this test would
automatically be run and the result
would be provided within 3 to 5 hours
for teaching Canada our product that
detects fungal infections typically in
hospitals the teaching candidate product
is being run before a patient would be
treated with an antifungal drug and
that's typically about 48 hours after a
patient may have entered a substance
protocol and again that would most often
occur within within the hospital or not
in the emergency department
thank you for that next one is bacterial
cultures grow faster than fungal is
there a clinical impact using the t2
bacterial panel compared to blood
culture yes published studies have shown
that the average time for a blood
culture to go positive for a bacterial
infection is about 29 hours and for
fungal infections it can be 48 to 72
hours on average now that average
sometimes it can be faster than that but
can also be as much as five days but are
now at an average of 29 hours where
again the species wouldn't be identified
potentially for another 12 hours after
that while it's still quicker than a
fungal infection we still have the
opportunity to reduce the time to result
by somewhere between 20 and 40 hours and
get patients on the right therapy 20 to
40 hours faster on it than they are
today on average and so remember the
mortality rates are increasing by about
8% for every hour of the way in cost to
treat the patient is increasing by 200
to 500 dollars per hour for delay so
despite the fact that bacteria grows
faster there are huge opportunities to
save lives and save cost by running the
t2 tests thank you
are there other applications of this
technology there are and we're really
excited about the other applications one
of the areas that we have developed is a
brand negative resistance panel we're
directly from a from a blood sample we
can provide a three to five hour result
on whether a patient might be resistant
to certain gram-negative infections
that's a product that will be available
early next year on a research use only
basis we also have developments in the
area of Canada
Oris where we work with the CDC around
super bug detection it was taking the
CDC on average 17 days to provide
results detecting Canada or us because
of certain limitations of blood culture
and again we were able to demonstrate
our ability to detect those infections
within three to five hours and then
finally we also have exciting
developments in the area of rapid Lyme
disease
where for the first time we're detecting
the bacteria associated with Lyme
disease directly from a patient's blood
sample thank you how you explained
discordant results where a teacher
result is positive and a blood culture
is negative
yes I can certainly occur and there's
two primary reasons for that the biggest
reason for that would be the low
sensitivity of blood culture if you do a
paired blood culture and a t2 result we
typically will pick up more infections
than blood culture but with you run
three or four blood cultures you're
going to start to get to the same
sensitivity of t2 the t2 system is so
sensitive that it really takes three or
four blood cultures to get to the same
level of sensitivity and in fact many
times we have many cases where blood
cultures been negative five or ten times
in our result is the confirmed as being
positive based on biopsies so it can
happen it's typically because of the
limitations of blood culture the other
cause of of a result though can be a
false positive if an environment is
contaminated or if a sample is
contaminated and this can happen for
both blood culture aunty too you can
sometimes have false positive results
that's why it's so important and we do
lab inspections and work really closely
with hospitals when we're implementing
our systems do you detect resistance
markers
yes we can detect resistance markers as
I mentioned we have a grande negative
resistance panel which will be offering
us sometime in the first half of next
year on a research use only basis and we
have further developments building
additional resistance markers that will
bring to market in the future thank you
you have time for one more questions are
the key to tests impacted by
antimicrobial therapy yes so that
they're not blood culture is so blood
culture is a process where you grow
cells and so if you put a patient on a
drug the presence of that drug impedes
the growth of the cells and it increases
that false negative test result the
blood culture can have especially when
patients are on drugs an hour at the a
clinical trial the FDA required us to
test drugs again to determine whether we
were affected by it and we're not and
it's all a part of our FDA label and it
should not affect us either because
we're not growing cells so we're not
dependent upon cell growth for detection
we're detecting the presence of intact
cells that are in the blood and again in
the interference studies that the FDA
required us to run we prove that that
does not in the presence of that
antimicrobial drug will not affect our
test result thank you I would like to
once again thank John McDonald for his
presentation would also like to thank
lab roots for making today's educational
webcast possible before we go I want to
let everyone know that today's webcast
will be available for on-demand viewing
through February 15 to 2019 you'll
receive an email from lab roots letting
you know when this webcast will be
available for replay please share that
announcement with your colleagues who
may have missed today's event that's all
for now thank you for joining us we hope
to see you again soon goodbye